(ding)
- Ladies and gentlemen, welcome aboard.
My name is Russell and
assisting me today will be
Xanax and Zoloft.
I'm here for your safety and
they're here for my comfort.
(energetic jazz music)
- I'm doing the safety
demo knowing full well
you're all ignoring me.
I might as well be doing the Macarena.
- There's absolutely no way
that that's going to fit
in the overhead compartment
but I'm gonna watch you try anyway.
- I'm not a bartender.
So I will not be granting
you a Bloody Mary
with Worcestershire sauce.
- Oh, is this your
newborn's first time flying?
How could you do that to us?
- There's no turbulence.
I just turned on the seat belt
sign because I want you to
stay the hell out of my way.
- Diet soda takes forever to pour.
Here's a regular one.
You won't know the difference.
- Pressing the call button repeatedly
isn't going to make me
tend to you any faster.
In fact, it's gonna make me go slower.
(pouring)
- When I said I would check your bag,
that was a courtesy, but you were rude
so now it's going to Baltimore.
- You know that vodka we just ran out of?
We use it to make crew
juice in the galley.
- Go ahead, tug my skirt one more time.
I dare you.
- I said pretzels or peanuts.
This isn't an all you
can eat buffet, honey.
- I have no idea what we're
flying over right now.
So I'll just say the Bahamas.
- Since you blatantly
ignored the seat belt sign,
I hope the turbulence
knocks you on your ass.
- Oh, you think I'm
coming through the cabin
to pick up your trash?
No, I'm crop-dusting.
Enjoy smelling my farts.
(energetic jazz music)